what exactly can the government do to
him
to any of us whether we're on the watch
list or not as a journalist my first
hunch is to go straight to the source
Michel German is a former FBI agent who
has experience with the terrorism watch
list what is the internal designation
given to people who are on that watch
list known or suspected terrorists do
you need to be a known or suspected
terrorist to be given that designation
no you do not there's plenty of evidence
that people were put on these lists were
investigated for no reasons so you're
building this expanding pool of suspects
based on little or no real evidence what
are the most extreme things that can
happen to you if you end up in that
system
there's so little transparency that we
don't know all the ways that the
watchlist might be used so from a
deprivation of rights standpoint there's
a lot you could lose let's say I'm you
know I'm an American citizen I get taken
into secondary screening surely I have
Fourth Amendment protections right not
at the border anything coming across the
border could be contraband and therefore
the government has a right to search it
without a warrant the agents that take
me to secondary screening have the
authority to read the contents of my
emails or my text messages and not just
read them but put them in a database for
other agents across the intelligence
community to read them all of that
information can be collected when you
cross the border so I think a lot of
people are not aware of this what you're
saying that is that at least some of our
constitutional protections don't exist
when we're in a border crossing or an
airport coming back from abroad right
you might try going to the airport
tomorrow and seeing how you do
[Music]
[Music]